I just wanna fix things and set a better
example for people because I don't like
where this is going and I don't like
watching and I'll just say it on the
grandest I don't like it watching it in
politics I don't like you know right now
we're in a scary time the feud between
Scooter Braun and Taylor Swift has taken
a scary turn and scooters speaking out I
think we need to go behind closed doors
and see if we can have a conversation
just hours after the 38 year old music
exec spoke publicly for the first time
about his beef with Taylor scooter hit
up social media to address the singer
directly revealing his family had
received numerous death threats since
she released a public statement last
week
yikes let's rewind this whole thing
started over the summer when Taylor
accused scooter of bullying after he
purchased her former label Big Machine
Records and in turn now owns her master
records then things got heated again
earlier this month when Taylor claimed
that big machines founder Scott
Borchetta and scooter were blocking her
from performing her older songs at the
American Music Awards and preventing the
release of an upcoming Netflix
documentary about her life then there
were a bunch of back-and-forth
statements from both camps including one
where big machine told Taylor the
narrative you have created does not
exist I would very much like to be
excluded from this narrative then Big
Machine said they'd reached an agreement
to allow Taylor to perform her songs at
the AMAs but the company behind the AMAs
Dick Clark Productions released a
statement saying any final agreement on
this matter needs to be made directly
with Taylor Swift's management team it's
it's just unbelievable okay back to
scooters insta post on Thursday he
opened up about the drama during a Q&A
at the 2019 entertainment industry
conference I think I'm not gonna go into
details here because this is not my
style
I
we live in a time of toxic division and
people thinking that social media is the
appropriate place to air out of each
other or not having conversations
yeah well all that changed when scooter
got home because he shared this lengthy
message to Instagram reading in part
quote since your public statement last
week there have been numerous death
threats directed at my family this
morning I spoke out publicly for the
first time saying I wouldn't participate
in a social media war however I came
home tonight to find my wife had
received a phone call threatening the
safety of our children
scooter shared one of the violent
threats he received posting this
screenshot in his insta story
scooter added quote I assume this was
not your intention but it is important
that you understand that your words
carry a tremendous amount of weight he
went on to say he was disappointed that
she had remained silent after allegedly
being notified by her attorney about the
ongoing threats but he added that he was
still hopeful they could resolve their
differences even though he claims she
had rejected all of his attempts to talk
it out with her over the last six months
quote at this point with safety becoming
a concern I have no choice other than to
publicly ask for us to come together and
try to find a resolution this game of
telephone isn't working he concluded his
plea writing I continue to wish you the
best and hope we can resolve this I hope
they resolve this like yesterday this
drama is a lot of course you can count
on ET to bring you all the latest in
this ongoing feud so make sure to keep
it locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]